thank the heavens that over watch this
first season of competitive mode is over
no more floundering around in the 40s
for me anymore we can finally begin a
new of crap well it's not all about
competitive mode Blizzard has introduced
a bunch of new changes in the lace
overwatch patch as well as balance
tweaks to a number of different heroes
including both the shimano brothers so
here are the five biggest changes in
season two of overwatch in last season's
competitive mode players were assigned
skill range from 1 to 100 which would
have been great if 60 wasn't considered
the best of the best but now the scale
goes all the way up to 5,000 bigger
numbers are always better I can assure
you that and this season players are
assigned to tears ranging from bronze
silver gold all the way up to Grand
Master yeah it will be nice to dream
about getting that many points but as a
proud okay player what I'm excited about
is that you won't drop out of a rank by
losing as long as you reach a certain
tier you won't fall any lower than that
for the rest of the season this time
around ranking up actually means
something and just bound to give players
a great sense of achievement when they
actually do
as one of the more difficult heroes in
the game to master Hanzo seemed destined
for improvements so this patch he
receives a couple of buffs increasing
both his walking speed while Amy and
also his arrow speed so this way players
will find it a lot easier to land shots
without having to predict where the
enemy will be but for me every kill I
make with him is still going to feel
like an accident too easy okay well
neither a gameplay change nor a balanced
week the new map I can vault is a
welcome addition to the game not only is
a town of beautiful and magnificent
sight to see it's also a map designed
with hiding places in mind there are
dozens of small buildings you can read
in and out of as well as a whole maze of
hallways inside the castle itself so you
combine that with some of the most
beautiful vistas Blizzard has ever
produced and you've got a map that's
destined for greatness
hey remember son death that incredibly
annoying tiebreaking mechanic that was
stupid and unfair unless of course you
want well I'm happy to report that
finally gone if a match ends in a tie
the game will instead grant teams
additional time on the clock with the
amount of time changing depending on the
map if it's still tied after that the
match will end in a draw with both teams
receiving a couple of competitive points
but at least we can all be thankful that
we'll never have to watch that stupid
coin flip ever again
well I can't say I didn't see this
coming Ginja was a monster last season
and everyone knew it simply hearing the
sound of his ultimate caused everyone to
run away and complain on the message
boards so Blizzard finally nerfed is
well everything let's take a look at his
laundry list of changes shall we first
off his double jump no longer resets
after wall climbing which means he won't
be able to hop around like a little
insect anymore that ya hear his swift
strike doesn't you'll damage the traps
anymore which means he can finally get
caught by junk rat now that's a nerf I
can get into also his swift strike
doesn't interrupt melee attacks anymore
meaning he won't be able to do is deadly
shorouk in melee combo which doesn't
sound too bad until you get to the final
nerve which also reduces ultimate time
from eight seconds to six the extra two
seconds sometimes felt like an eternity
when the opposing gandules hacking up
your whole team so those are some of the
biggest changes in what might be one of
over watches biggest content patches to
date there are tons of other little
additions to the game such as friendly
health bars and even new remotes but
what do you think the biggest changes
are all right the skills here is a good
thing did Genji get nerfed too hard let
me know in the comments below and I'll
see you on the steps of I can ball
Oh